it's a bullying Capcom exclusive power
98.3 man Ready Set Radio you already
know what it is we live on the bus right
now this guy has got the number 2 album
in the country independently I might add
all the way from Seattle man we got a
welcome to homie Macklemore to the shows
I've read it man I'm sure man out here
in Arizona hey you actually went to the
mall today and you've got yourself a
traditional Mexican getup
you got some ostrich boots right here
Shingo bling would be proud of you bro
yeah I mean I kind of I kind of cut some
corners
you got the belt buckle tonight the belt
buckle all of this is definitely not
ostrich like I had the option to get
ostrich you had the option to get the
real license or the or the face like at
least the the shoes and the belt but you
know oh it's a good look I feel like I'm
gonna pull it off
I feel like me at Halloween time is
perfect on a budget in Arizona a.m.
let's talk about your album The Heist
with Ryan Lewis you guys to me really
made like some serious history we kind
of talked off off off you know the air a
little bit but I really feel like this
is one of the first times like I feel
like a truly independent hip-hop album
is really like came out of nowhere man I
wouldn't have to say him out of nowhere
but to the big labels to lay a
traditional hip hop music who the hell
is this Macklemore guy like did you
expect like what did you expect to
happen without him came out did you even
expect anything you know was that even
in your head going number two no
definitely not like I follow I get sound
scanning right we I too
my homework I study the industry and I
thought that we would do like 28 to like
33 and we should be great look I was
like as long as we break 20 I'm gonna be
happy right and we did 78 so I had no
idea I didn't think you know I think a
big and there's a lot of contributing
factors to it but you know we streamed
it like a week early on NPR and people
you know that link really got around I
didn't even think that it would get
around like that I thought that we might
be able to hit some like older
demographic or people that weren't
really our fans and it blew up with our
fans of blew up you know with people
that had never heard of us and it just
kind of went from there and people
really liked the music so I think that a
stream can kind of help you know if the
music's good I think I can't hurt you if
it's not people liked it's definitely
better yeah there's there's something
that I really respect you for and that's
I always feel like the whole gay
marriage issue is like our civil rights
movement absolutely don't I'm saying
absolutely as far as equal rights
they're all human beings you know I
think I think it's just it's amazing to
see an MC come out with like a stand
like a song that same love is it's such
a beautiful record Thank You Man um when
you met when you put that out like were
you scared like any sort of like
blowback from the hip-hop community you
know man hip-hop is a homophobic
absolutely onre it's it's it's I mean I
think it's finally starting to move away
from that guys are correct yourself who
stands up for you know that kind of
thing and then you know with Frank Ocean
coming out sure that was major that's me
but were you were you were you like if
he at all about it yeah you know I was
definitely um
you know you write a record like that
you're like how are my peer is going to
react very honest record - yeah you know
like when I was in the third grade I
thought that I was gay that's the first
two bars of the song or first part of
the song so and some some random kid in
Harlem here's other play like yeah
exactly him so I was aware of that to me
you put it on a scale and you're like
you know am I worried about those like
you know those people that are gonna
judge me yeah and and take it for you
know whatever they want to take it as
but judge me and label me and not agree
with my stance on it or am I going to
think about humanity and the masses and
the civil rights issue that it is and
you put it on a scale and it's a
no-brainer to put that out
I was definitely a part of me was scared
but I think that that's where some of
the best music is comes from is like
[ __ ] that challenges me that makes me
like question is just the right move is
this something that people are going to
accept it doesn't matter like it comes
down to what I believe in and that's a
record in the stands that I believe in
and I'm I'm glad it actually it's not
the type of song there's definitely been
fans that are like oh Macklemore I lost
all respect for you you read you know
who comments and [ __ ] people are
definitely I'm still ignorant still
ignorant but at the end of the day this
support has completely out waited and
you know the message has really gotten
out in there and that's what it that's
what's important that's what I just
watched the mini little documentary that
dropped a few days ago yeah
the jabari yeah yeah it was really dope
and I saw that I've grown up in a family
full of people have been addicts and in
the interview or in the documentary I
didn't know that you had an addiction
and you were going to rehab yeah what if
you don't mind sharing what was your
choice of what was your addiction yeah I
was just like always the type of dude
that never had any sort of moderation
like the first time that I drank alcohol
I was 14 15 years old in the kitchen by
myself listening in the pack I took like
15 shots because I was - [ __ ] yeah like
I you know in the in the white beater in
the kitchen in like 90 pounds
speculative tears that's feeling myself
and by myself you know like I never had
moderation from that very first time and
as I got older you know mostly it was it
was alcohol and we'd like I smoked we
like I broke Wiz Khalifa I didn't ever
know when to stop so it was just like
the first thing I would do was just you
know smell the blood and the day would
persist on that type of tip
you know and I was just broken unhappy
and I could never write music in this
thing like a lot of people you know a
lot of it's norrison yeah little Wayne
yeah Wayne like tons of people tons of
people like that's their lifestyle and
they're able to be productive right and
I could just never write like that you
know I get like freestyle and I could
perform not to the best of my ability
but I could do it but in terms of
writing raps I just stare at the paper
so you know and then you know you had
like some pills and some and some cough
syrup and as it got bad towards the end
but you know it was mostly just having
no moderation with any substance at all
a lot of things yeah it was a lot of
things and you know my pops finally came
to me and was like you know you're 20 26
years old or 25 years old whatever I was
and what are you doing like you don't if
you're gonna do this music thing like do
it but you can't do it continuously like
you know getting messed up like this so
I finally went to treatment and you know
really got the tools that I needed to
you know remain sober that's great see
that that's dope that you you know you
talk about that kind of thing because
it's not really the coolest thing in the
world to be a sober hip-hop artist gay
man who supports gay marriage oh no I
mean but that's that's a way that um you
know I I my story isn't a conventional
or like you know a stereotypical story
and I think that that's why people have
been able to relate to me because
addiction is a big part of you know our
society in general just part of humanity
whether it's whatever yeah exactly like
addiction
and I think that if you if you sure
about it in a way that's not like
preaching but it's honest and you hold
yourself accountable people can relate
to it and that's what's happened
when did you start rapping what age did
you know I hey I'm just you know I'm
sure you were wrapping your kid or you
messing around with a shirt I mean I was
like in high school trying to write raps
yeah they were terrible but once a month
what point it's a time where you like
you know what I'm gonna be a rapper
like that's what I'm gonna pursue you
know what I I don't think that there was
ever like a distinction between like
being like a hobby rapper and like I'm
gonna do this there was obviously like a
financial difference there happened at
some point but in terms of like when I
first started rapping 14 years old I was
like I'm gonna rap like I'd wanted to
rap since I was in like third grade
hoarse so taking chest and you know but
I you know I'd always wanted to be
onstage I was just that little wild kid
that was like man I'm trying to you know
perform at the family gatherings and
well a stuntman lip-sync and you know
talent shows and you know I remember we
had it we had a little group that we
formed that diggable planers was real
pop in when I was yeah that's used to be
my [ __ ] and we you know I was like
butterfly and on homie we got a home
girl to be a what was her name
ladybug and Doodlebug and you know we
used to just always mess around and want
to be performers so it just kind of was
a natural progression once you know hit
14:15 and bought a karaoke tape deck and
you know the rest was history now